- [Man] If you were to
start all over again
- Yep.
- [Man] From scratch.
- Yes.
- [Man] No budget.
- [Man] And you wanted
to start a tech company,
what would you do?
- I'd go work for somebody that I admire
for free for four years.
- [Man] Can you name someone you admire?
(audience laughs)
- I would try to get to Jeff Bezos
and work for him for free.
- [Man] For free?
- For free.
For four years.
I would literally sleep on
the couch of an acquaintance
and eat fast-food for 99 cents a day
for four years to work for Jeff Bezos.
Fuck, I might be willing
to do that right now.
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
(hip-hop music)
I believe in 20 years
it will be common place
for individuals to pay
the best business leaders
to work for them, not
the other way around.
It's a very weird thing that's starting
to manifest in my head because it's
just black and white to me
that that's where the value is.
Get as close to the sun of
the thing that you wanna be,
and you will win if you're capable.
And you hear, now that I've
gotten curious about it,
you start watching these documentaries
or you dig into the successful people.
The amount of people that
started off as grabbing coffee
for the guy or the gal
that they wanted to be
and then became it.
I would do that my man.
I would or, or, the thing
is it's back to guessing.
It's funny, the Bezos
thing or somebody else.
The other thing I would do try
to get very close to the voice space
but it's funny how I don't wanna go there
because I wouldn't know which
founder was the good one
to build on top of the voice space.
So I went to the platform or
something that I established.
But I genuinely believe
that when you're young,
time is your biggest leverage.
And that what you should
do is build leverage
with the leaders of the world.
If you wanna be a hip-hop
mogul, go work for Puff Daddy
for free for three years, right?
We're so pressured by our
parents to start making money
at 22, 23.
I think everybody should
legitimately have totally different
strategy from 22 to 30.
For everybody here over 45,
you know how young 30 is.
(audience laughs)
And I think everybody here
who's 45, 50, if I said:
Hey what about spending 22 to 30
and only working for the person
you admired the most for free?
I think a lot more people
would have taken that
up on than what they actually did.
Which is do bullshit to pay for their rent
and like just dumb shit.
Very intriguing to me that that's
where the leverage is gonna go.
If you wanna be a great creative,
whoever the 10 best creative
directors in the world
now have the leverage.
So that's what I would do.
Thank you guys.
(audience claps)
Thank you.
- Patience
- It is the imperative
foundation of anything
that is long-term successful.
- Why?
- Because when you are impatient
person or organization,
you tend to make short-term
decisions which have been
proven historically as
something that creates
a vulnerable usually to long-term growth.
What's up vlog?
Just going to the airport now in Oslo
on our way to Copenhagen, then to Moscow.
Back in the USSR as they say.
Anyway, good talk this
morning at breakfast.
Just had a huge meeting with
Eric in the back of the cab.
So many people wasting
time, I just basically
had a London office
meeting on the way here.
That's how ya hack it.
Sometimes having somebody
travel, the expense is worth it
because the ROI of the
meeting and the serendipity
things like a cab ride
make a ROI positive.
Continue to hack your
time for your dollars.
- We're good, just checking the lighting.
(Gary laughs)
- I tweeted the other
day 0% of zero is zero.
A lot of people laughed and made jokes
but it's funny somebody
was negotiating against me
in some business world where
they were gonna take zero commission.
And on this thing, I don't
wanna be too specific.
Anyway, which I replied to the
person they were pitching it to.
I'm like cool, when they bring you nothing
it's not gonna matter. (laughs)
0% of zero is zero is
zero for that company,
that person so, you can pass on my 20%
but when I bring 400,000, you'd get 320.
When that person brings you
zero, you're gonna get zero.
Always wonder why somebody
is willing to work on zero commission.
It's either because they're unbelievable
and they're making
money in some other spot
in that overall relationship,
or it's cause they can't
deliver in that craft.
This situation was the
second one. (man laughs)
That entity is not going
to bring you anything.
- [Man] People love you man.
- 'Cause I love them first.
- (gasps) I waited three hours.
I have to go in 100
seconds, I want to just.
- You got it.
- Because I love you.
Thanks everything man.
- You're welcome man.
I think people should sleep
six, seven, eight hours
depending on your body.
I'm a huge advocate in
what the fuck are you doing
the other 18 hours, right?
And so when I hear your question
the answer is of course you should.
You know you should.
You you know you should
test, everybody here should
spend meaningful amounts
of time testing everything.
Everything!
That's what your suppose to be doing
'cause you don't know the
answer for your specific nuance
if Linkedin or a podcast
or influencer marketing
or you know, you don't
know if that's gonna be the
turning point and what you're
doing is your doing too many things.
People are keeping their time precious
when it's their biggest asset.
People are not reinvesting
money back into their business
'cause they wanna buy dumb shit.
People are not trying
things because if they fail,
they worry about what other
people think about that failure.
And so we're all, you know the
answer is yes, to everything.
Literally fuck it, I'm like yes.
And I could leave and go
fucking fly to LA right now
because the next three hours is yes.
(audience laughs)
It is, yes so of course you should.
Like, what are you doing
for 18 hours a day?
Find a hour and do it for a hour everyday
to get to the answer
and then also understand
that the first 10 times you
do it, it might not be right.
Because it's like, I
always talk about the ROI.
People are like, what's
the ROI of influencers?
Or VR?
Or the ROI of those 10 hours
reaching out to influencers?
The ROI of a basketball is
very different to people.
To me it's nothing, to Lebron
James it's a billion dollars.
So, all this stuff works.
It's are you good at it?
Is a whole nother question.
So it's not just the ROI of trying it,
then you gotta get good at it.
Nothing you're good at right now,
you were so great at the
first time you tired it.
So, of course man, like
everything that's happening,
you need to figure out how
it works for your business.
B to B, B to C, personal brand.
The question is, what are
you doing with your time?
You know, and so that's
why I get mad at people
who want to be an entrepreneur
and watch four hours of
Netflix a weekend or.
And by the way people need escapism.
You need to check out, you need to rest.
You have to be in a mental
place but the scrutiny
that we have to put on our
time as young entrepreneurs,
you know it's just time or money.
Talent is the variable that sits in here.
But the assets that you're sitting with,
in the beginning your time
and then you amass money.
And then you can use
the money to save time
and you're just going back and forth.
And everybody wants these big dreams
and they're not willing to
work at the level they need to
when that's the advantage they have.
So, fuck yes you should.
Yeah, I'm really looking forward
to the flight to Moscow and
more importantly Moscow to LA.
- What are we doing in Moscow
- That's crazy.
- We're in the airport for eight hours.
I assume we have lounge
and we're just gonna
fall asleep in the corner on
a chair that looks like this.
That's what we're gonna do. (laughs)
I mean honestly I'm very excited.
I've never been to the USSR.
- Aw that's crazy
- Since I've left in 1970.
So it's actually a fun day but
I can't leave
- You can't leave.
Well, you can't leave right because
you need a Visa.
- You need a Visa.
And I didn't know I
was, I didn't even know
until two days ago that we
were connecting through Moscow.
- [Man] That would have been nice though.
- Just to run to Red
Square and do a meetup
would have been awesome.
It's inspired me to wanna go back.
I don't know what we're
gonna do but yeah I'm tired.
- Alright can we get the last ones seated.
We only have 10 minutes till Gary leaves.
- I felt pretty good about that.
I'm really excited to see
everybody here in Copenhagen.
Incredible, incredible
city, really good day.
- [Man] Yeah, great day.
- Got some good content.
- We have a lot to go yet.
- It was a lot, yes we still. (laughs)
We have to go to the airport.
We gotta go, three, four
hour flight to Moscow,
eight hour layover in Moscow.
- You have a drinks meeting.
- I have a drinks meeting?
- [Man] That's where you gotta go next.
- Fuck.
I'm a much bigger brand than VaynerMedia.
- Yeah.
- Yet I service no clients.
- Okay.
- And it was because I knew
that that was the trap hole.
And you know again, remember I
said I fucked up with Google?
- Yeah, yeah.
- When you do it, you know,
you did the right thing.
But now the right thing
in this mature state
when you recognize it,
is the power of know.
Because if we're here three
years later and you're like
Gary, remember?
I'm like yeah, the guy
with the two earrings.
Now there's no excuse.
Now that you know, now it's
just down to execution.
(man asks question)
Yeah, I mean there's a
couple ways to go about it.
You're like, I'm sorry.
You can't have me.
I've built it up.
I've built my team.
Or you can go a different route.
Oh, okay Rick, Sarah,
Hans-Shmanz, like you want me?
Well, what we told you 5000 a month
is actually 30,000 a month if you want me.
There's a lot of moves that you can have.
There's always gonna be an excuse.
You're 100% in charge.
You know what the issue is,
either address it or don't.
There's one of two ways.
You do what I, I've scaled
that and I've done it
by hiring around two things.
One, everything I don't wanna do.
Two, everything I know I'm not as good at
than the other things
that I spend my time on.
Which means I spend 30% of my time on HR.
Like you look at my
calendar, I'm just meeting
with my employees talking
about somebody else
that they're mad at.
But that's what I do so special
that allows me to build
what I build, right?
So, it's about leaving money on the table
in the short term, my friend.
You're trying to maximize the profit
instead of reinvesting it into people
and having people do B versus your A.
It's about building a
business in five years
instead of one year.
Similar to him, nobody wants
to give up the short term.
He says yes for another 50,000
or 25,000 or 2000 a month
or whatever it is, instead of saying no.
And then, you know, 'cause
it's exciting to take.
People get caught up in
top-line revenue or profit.
And it's always about
tweaking those two things.
Also ego hurts these stories a lot.
You like the feeling of
being the best of the best.
I listen to every word, you know?